In the last video, I hinted that
things were about to get wacky.
And they are.
So if we start where we
left off in the last video,
we started right over here,
looking at the distance
to the nearest star.
And just as a reminder,
in this drawing
right here, this
depiction right here,
this circle right here,
this solar system circle,
it's not the size of the Sun.
It's not the size of the
orbits of the Earth, or Pluto,
or the Kuiper Belt.
This is close to the
size of the Oort Cloud.
And the actual orbit of
Earth is about-- well,
the diameter of the orbit
of Earth is about 1/50,000
of this.
So you wouldn't
even see it on this.
It would not even make
up a pixel on this screen
right here, much
less the actual size
of the Sun or
something much smaller.
And just remember that
orbit of the Earth,
that was at a huge distance.
It takes eight minutes for
light to get from the Sun
to the Earth, this
super long distance.
If you shot a bullet
at the Sun from Earth,
it would take you that 17 years
to actually get to the Sun.
So one thing, this huge
distance wouldn't even
show up on this picture.
Now, what we saw
in the last video
is that if you travel at
unimaginably fast speeds,
if you travel at 60,000
kilometers per hour--
and I picked that
speed because that's
how fast Voyager 1
actually is traveling.
That's I think
the fastest object
we have out there
in space right here.
And it's actually kind of
leaving the solar system
as we speak.
But even if you were
able to get that fast,
it would still take 80,000
years, 75,000 or 80,000 years,
to travel the 4.2 light
years to the Alpha Centauri
cluster of stars.
To the nearest star, it
would take 80,000 years.
And that scale of time is
already an amount of time
that I have trouble
comprehending.
As you can imagine, all
of modern civilization
has occurred, well, definitely
in the last 10,000 years.
But most of recorded history
is in the last 4,000 or 5,000
years.
So this is 80,000 years to
travel to the nearest star.
So it's a huge distance.
Another way to think about
it is if the Sun were
the size of a basketball and you
put that basketball in London,
if you wanted to do it in scale,
the next closest star, which
is actually a
smaller basketball,
right over here, Proxima
Centauri, that smaller
basketball you would have
to put in Kiev, Ukraine
in order to have
a similar scale.
So these are basketballs
sitting in these cities.
And you would have to
travel about 1,200 miles
to place the next basketball.
And these basketballs
are representing
these super huge things that
we saw in the first video.
The Sun, if you actually
made the Earth relative
to these basketballs, these
would be little grains of sand.
So there are any little
small planets over here,
they would have to
be grains of sand
in Kiev, Ukraine versus the
grain of sand in London.
So this is a massive,
massive distance,
already, at least in
my mind, unimaginable.
And when it gets
really wacky is when
you start really
looking at this.
Even this is a super,
super small distance
relative to the galactic scale.
So this whole depiction of kind
of our neighborhood of stars,
this thing over here is
about, give or take--
and we're doing rough
estimates right here--
it's about 30 light years.
I'll just do LY for short.
So that's about 30 light years,
And once again, you can
take pictures of our galaxy
from our point of view.
But you actually can't take
a picture of the whole galaxy
from above it.
So these are going to
be artists' depictions.
But if this is 30 light years,
this drawing right here of kind
of our local neighborhood
of the galaxy,
this right here is roughly-- and
these are all approximations.
Let me do this in
a darker color.
This is about 1,000 light years.
And this is the
1,000 light years
of our Sun's neighborhood,
if you can even
call it a neighborhood anymore.
Even this isn't really a
neighborhood if it takes you
80,000 years to get to
your nearest neighbor.
But this whole
drawing over here--
now, it would take forever
to get anywhere over here--
it would be 1/30 of this.
So it would be about that
big, this whole drawing.
And what's really
going to blow your mind
is this would be roughly
a little bit more
than a pixel on this
drawing right here, that
spans a 1,000 light years.
But then when you
start to really
put it into
perspective-- so now,
let's zoom out a little bit--
so this drawing right here,
this 1,000 light years is
now this 1,000 light years
over here.
So this is the local
vicinity of the Sun.
And once again,
the word "local" is
used in a very liberal
way at this point.
So this right here
is 1,000 light years.
If you're sitting
here and you're
looking at an object
that's sitting--
let me do this in
a darker color--
if we're sitting here on Earth
and we're looking at an object
out here that's 500
light years away,
we're looking at it as it was
500 years ago because the light
that is reaching our
eyeballs right now,
or our telescopes
right now, left
this guy over here
500 years ago.
In fact, he's not going
to even be there anymore.
He probably has moved
around a little bit.
So just even on
this scale, we're
talking about these
unimaginably huge distances.
And then when we
zoom out, this is
kind of our local part of
the galaxy right over here.
This piece right here, this
is called the Orion Spur.
And people are still
trying to work out
exactly the details
of the actual shape
the Milky Way Galaxy,
the galaxy that we're in.
But we're pretty
sure-- actually,
we're very sure-- we
have these spiral arms
and we have these
spurs off of them.
But it's actually very hard to
come up with the actual shape,
especially because you can't
see a lot of the galaxy,
because it's kind of
on the other side,
on the other side of the center.
But really just to get
a sense of something
that at least-- I mean it blows
my mind if you really think
about what it's saying--
these unbelievable distances
show up as a little dot here.
This whole drawing
shows up as a dot here.
Now when we zoom out,
over here that dot
would no longer even show up.
It wouldn't even
register a pixel
on this drawing right over here.
And then this whole drawing,
this whole thing right
over here, this whole picture
is this grid right over here.
It is this right over here.
So hopefully, that gives you
a sense of how small even
our local neighborhood
is relative to the galaxy
as a whole.
And the galaxy as a whole,
just to give you a sense,
has 200 to 400 billion stars.
Or maybe I should say
solar systems just
to give you a sense that
when we saw the solar system,
it's not just the Sun.
There's all this
neat, dynamic stuff.
And there are planets, and
asteroids, and solar winds.
And so there's 200
to 400 billion stars
and for the most part, 200
and 400 billion solar systems.
So it's an unimaginably, I
guess, complex or huge place.
And just to make
it clear, even when
we zoom in to this
picture right here,
and I think it was obvious
based on telling you about this,
that these little white
pockets right here,
this isn't one star.
This isn't two stars.
These are thousands
of stars here.
So when you go over here,
each little blotch of white
that you see, that's not a star,
that's not a thousand stars.
We're starting to talk
in the millions of stars
when you look at certain
blotches here and there.
I mean, maybe it might be
one star that's closer to you
or might be a million
stars that are far apart
and that are just
relatively close together.
And everything has to be used
in kind of loose terms here.
And we'll talk more
about other galaxies.
But even this isn't the
upper bound of galaxies.
People believe the
Andromeda Galaxy
has a trillion stars in it,
a trillion solar systems.
We're talking about these
huge, huge, immense distances.
And so just to give you a sense
of where we fit in the picture,
this is a rough
location of our Sun.
And remember, that little
dot I drew just now
is including millions of stars,
millions of solar systems,
already unimaginable
the distances.
But if you really want
to get at the sense
relative to the whole galaxy,
this is an artist's depiction.
Once again, we could
never obviously get
this perspective on the galaxy.
It would take us
forever to travel this
far so that you could see
the galaxy from above.
But this is our
best guess looking
at things from
our vantage point.
And we actually can't even
see this whole area over here
because it's on the other side
of the center of the galaxy,
which is super, super
dense and super bright.
And so it's very hard to see
things on the other side.
We think-- or actually there's
a super massive black hole
at the center of the galaxy.
And we think that they're at the
center of all or most galaxies.
But you know the whole point
of this video, actually
this whole series of videos,
this is just kind of-- I
don't know-- to put you in awe
a little bit of just how huge
this is.
Because when you really
think about the scale--
I don't know-- no words
can really describe it.
But just to give
you a sense, we're
about 25,000 light years from
the center of the galaxy.
So even when we look at things
in the center of the galaxy,
that's as they were
25,000 years ago.
It took 25,000 years for
that light to get to us.
I mean when that light left
the center of the galaxy,
I won't even guess to
think what humanity
was like at that point in time.
So it's these huge distances
in the whole galaxy over here.
And once again,
like solar systems,
it's hard to say the edge of the
galaxy, because there's always
going to be a few more stars
and other things orbiting
around the galaxy as you
go further and further out,
but it gets less
dense with stars.
But the main density,
the main disk,
is about 100,000 light years.
100,000 light years is
the diameter roughly
of the main part of the galaxy.
And it's about 1,000
light years thick.
So you can kind of
imagine it as this disk,
this thing that's fairly flat.
But it's 1,000
light years thick.
It's 1,000 light years thick.
You would have to do this
distance 250 times just
to go from the top part of
the galaxy to the bottom part,
much less going
across the galaxy.
So it might seem
relatively flat.
But it's still immensely,
immensely thick.
And just as another
way to visualize it,
if this thing right over here
that includes the Oort Cloud,
roughly a light year in
diameter, is a grain of sand,
a millimeter in
diameter grain of sand,
then the universe
as a whole is going
to be the diameter
of a football field.
And that might tell you, OK,
those are two tractable things.
I can imagine a grain of sand,
a millimeter wide grain of sand
in a football field.
But remember, that
grain of sand is still
50,000 or 60,000 times the
diameter of Earth's orbit.
And Earth's orbit,
it would still
take a bullet or something
traveling as fast as a jet
plane 15 hours to just go
half of that-- or sorry,
not-- 15 years or 17 years,
I forgot the exact number.
But it was 15, 16, 17
years to even cover
half of that distance.
So 30 years just to cover the
diameter of Earth's orbit.
That's 1/60,000 of our little
grain of sand in the football
field.
And just to kind
of really, I don't
know, have an appreciation
for how mind-blowing
this really is, this is actually
a picture of the Milky Way
Galaxy, our galaxy,
from our vantage point.
As you can see,
we're in the galaxy
and this is looking
towards the center.
And even this picture, you start
to appreciate the complexity
of what 100 billion stars are.
But what I really
want to point out
is even in this
picture, when you're
looking at these things,
some of these things
that look like stars,
those aren't stars.
those are thousands of
stars or millions of stars.
Maybe it could be
one star closer up.
But when we're
starting to approach
the center of the
galaxy, these are
thousands and
thousands and millions
of stars or solar systems that
we're actually looking at.
So really, it starts
to boggle the mind
to imagine what might actually
be going on over there.